die beisetzung der queen wird das erste
staatsbegräbnis seit der beisetzung von
winston churchill und die war im jahr
1965 eine gigantische zeremonie ein
moment für die geschichtsbücher
und natürlich auch eine logistische
herkulesaufgabe
aber von wem wird das ganze eigentlich
finanziert zeiten sie sich fest vom
britischen steuerzahler und die genaue
summe die wird vom königshaus nicht
bekannt gegeben aber schon jetzt sind
die schätzungen der britischen kollegen
gigantisch
operation london bridge eine logistische
höchstleistung für england ein immenser
finanzieller aufwand für das volk seit
dem tod der queen vor elf tagen wird ein
jahrelang minutiös ausgeklügelter plan
umgesetzt was passiert wann wie und wo
nach dem ableben der rekordmonat der
abschied ihrer majestät exakt
protokolliert
die beisetzung der königin das erste
staatsbegräbnis seit winston churchill
1965 trauerfeier in dieser größenordnung
teuer die kosten trägt der steuerzahler
ausnahmezustand in großbritannien der
staat sagt für queen elizabeth der
zweite
überdimensional in jeglicher hinsicht
autokorsos helikopterflüge toten wachen
prozessionen das begräbnis wird
landesweit live übertragen
in 125 kinos in kathedralen vor dem
königlichen palast in edinburgh die
sicherheitskräfte in alarmbereitschaft
geheimdienste polizisten britisches
militär spezialkräfte für
terrorbekämpfung sie sorgen für den
schutz der bevölkerung schirmen
spitzenpolitiker aus aller welt ab unter
den 2000 geladenen gästen 500
staatsoberhäupter die kosten zum
vergleich die beisetzung von queen mum
2002 kostet etwas mehr als sechs
millionen euro die trauerfeier von
prinzessin diana 1997
schlägt mit etwa drei bis fünf millionen
zu buche die beerdigung von prinz philip
im vergangenen jahr kostet nur einen
bruchteil grund die korona pandemie
verhindert größere feierlich
alles peanuts die beisetzung der queen
die zusätzlichen feiertage und die
krönung von könig charles dem dritten im
kommenden jahr das alles wird den
britischen steuerzahler wohl insgesamt
fast sieben milliarden euro kosten die
faszination monarchie man muss sie sich
leisten können und wollen
[Musik]